[Music]
it's been nine years since I've used my
powers and this city is getting more and
more dangerous every moment you pose
were given to you for a reason if I
can't save the world Gaby but you can
save you a piece of it but this
neighborhood
[Music]
Lightning is back
but you were done being a hero brother
things all the exercise he can get black
lightning series premiere Tuesday
January 16 happy Festivus everyone we
got lightning hands going all over the
air over so I'll explain what's up with
this new dark blitzkrieg flash as well
as what's going on with Black Lightning
which is starting in January there been
so many questions about what's going on
with this new dark flash who's called
the Blitzkrieg flash who is Barry
himself from Earth X and why he didn't
appear during the crossover episodes
normally the calculus that I used to
explain big plot holes in crossover
series is actually much easier to
explain in this case so the producers
actually said what's going on with this
animated series and why the characters
are different the continuity issues with
the live-action version of the crossover
so then obviously we got all that black
lightning stuff too which is a little
bit separate but I'll explain how that's
connected to the arrow verse but be sure
to subscribe to get everything because
it's the holidays there is a new round
of the flash ring giveaway that I'll
explain at the end of the video starting
with the dark flash first so he's part
of the new bikes men this is taking
place before the events of the
live-action crossover it's taken from
the animated Ray in the freedom fighters
series so there's a couple of different
versions of the Ray character but for
the most part the characters that you
see in this animated series are meant to
be the same thing as the live-action
versions of the characters there's just
a lot of continuity errors because
behind the scenes we found out that the
producers just argued about how
connected it should be to the
live-action shows because they had the
idea for the animated series a long time
before they'd nailed down the
live-action crossover which they
actually did start earlier this year so
because it takes a lot longer to get
animation out they had to start that
before they knew exactly how the
live-action crossover was gonna play out
so for the most part they're calling
this a prequel in the inconsistencies in
the dark flash the Blitzkrieg flash in
the reverse flash of the crossover will
be explained in a comic book much much
later so before they wipe it all under
the rug the simple explainer is is that
because this is taking place before the
events of the live-action crossover dark
Blache here who's called the Blitzkrieg
flash is killed by the freedom fighters
in a big fight then
reverse-flash shows up alters their
timeline and that explains some of the
continuity errors they might take a
different tactic when they try to
explain why things are so different in
what happened to ethics Barry during the
live-action crossover but for the most
part reverse-flash changing the timeline
is the easiest way to do that they
haven't changed any of the way the
characters powers work obviously this
version of Barry would not be with iris
because they're all Nazis the Fuhrer has
been known to frown on people who are
not of the Aryan race this actually
sounds like it's when Oliver has already
become the Fuhrer because they said that
Hitler died during the 90s of old age
but for the most part if you want to see
more of him there's only six episodes of
this series but it's just cool to see an
alternate version of Barry and at some
point during the holiday season I'll do
a map of the multiverse and all the
different versions of the flash that
we've seen so far I'll do some sort of
montage video those are always fun to
make but getting into black lightning if
you didn't know the show is going to
premiere after the flash when that comes
back January 16th
so normally legends is after flash every
week Black Lightning is taking that spot
because the legends isn't coming back to
a February I've already done a video
explaining all these crazy schedule
changes all I don't link to that at the
end of this but for the most part Black
Lightning has his comic book origin
story albeit with the typical arrow
burst changes so they made it more
contemporary if you're familiar with the
Riverdale school type setting they've
incorporated a lot of that but it's more
like characters out of the Superman
universe done in the tone of arrow more
of a dark gritty urban thriller albeit
with that family twist so both of his
daughters do have powers so imagine a
version of the West family if Joe West
were a superhero and his children Wally
and iris both had powers now Ollie does
have powers because he's Kid Flash but
even though there's been all that
speculation about Wally going on a
different TV series like Titans or
legends of tomorrow I don't think that
he's going to Black Lightning but he
would be one of the funny characters to
cross over because of all the jokes you
could make about the fact that they
channel lightning based powers and Wally
gives off dark matter lightning it'd be
interesting to see what happens if they
bring them for the crossover next year
the producers have been very cagey about
they're gonna deal with that because
this show shoots in Atlanta so
technically it's supposed to be
connected to the arrow verse but they're
not gonna cross the show's over anytime
soon maybe not till season two if we are
I feel like the way that we have scaled
up the crossovers over the years like
the first year was basically just arrow
versus flash and a couple people went to
Central City a couple people came to
Star City next year it gets a little
bigger with the introduction of the
legends the next year all of a sudden
it's it's four shows and we have Melissa
coming over to ours and and then this
year I really did enjoy in the first act
how they just made the dominators seem
so last year and just showed you the
type of scale that they're that we were
looking for this year I personally think
that I don't know how we scale up more
and I think like unless all the
productions shut down and we I don't
know just just shoot it like you would a
feature film but what you could do I
think is you could make it a little bit
more of a character based story and you
know maybe maybe it's about you know one
or two characters from each show you
know being sequestered out somewhere I
don't know a writer I just say the words
and then after the fact I critiques them
but I certainly create nothing on my own
if Stephen Amell is convinced that
they're gonna cross over at some point
eventually then it'll probably happen
but I wouldn't worry about that during
season 1 of Black Lightning just assume
that it exists by itself so I will say
far and away this latest trailer that
they just dropped on Christmas Eve is so
much better than the previous trailers
the music is better the action is better
so I'm just much more excited after
seeing the recent footage than I am
after those first couple of trailers
back at Comic Con a part of that is
because they release those trailers
right after they film the pilot and
typically TV shows need a couple
episodes to figure themselves out even
the flash changed a little bit over the
first half of season 1 and it's called
the best season 2 the flash so far but
it took a while to get there so what
will happen in January is is I will do a
video for episode 1 I'll see how
everybody feels about Black Lightning
and if it's popular enough on my channel
then I'll just keep
doing weekly videos for the episodes so
no worries we'll figure it out but
everybody let me know in the comments
how do you feel about black lightning so
far even if you don't know anything
about the character from the comics
which I will talk about when we start
doing episode videos I'll do comic book
Easter eggs like I would normally do
there should also be some more Titans in
the next couple of weeks we'll probably
find out what the other characters
costumes look like hopefully they look
as cool as the Robin costume
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner J man Joestar please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I'll just name a new winner the
next time I post DC click here for that
new flash trailer and to learn about all
the schedule changes and click here for
brand new Deadpool thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight